all right eyewear retailer Warby Parker
has been a pioneer since its founding in
2010 it's glasses start at $95 and allow
customers to choose ship and try them on
from the comfort of their homes fast
company named it one of the most
innovative companies three years in a
row as other retailers closed stores
Warby Parker has grown to 47 locations
in 22 states the latest just opened in
Philadelphia where it all began four
co-founders and co-ceos Neil Blumenthal
and Dale Dave Gilboa
joining us now welcome to you both or
should we call you mr. Warby and mr.
Parker first where did the name come
from because because it's not your names
yeah it came from too early Jack Kerouac
characters that we discovered at the New
York Public Library
simple as that yeah cool name
it is a cool name this when you started
in Philly when you guys were in gret in
grad school what was the business model
you thought was gonna work here we
thought that it was gonna be purely
online because we wanted to sell our
product directly to customers is that
what it allow us to bypass the middlemen
and transfer all that saving to
customers but we soon found out that
people want to touch the the glasses in
person and we launched the features in
Vogue and GQ the company took off like a
rocket ship we had a wait list of 20,000
people people start calling up saying
hey can we come to your office to try on
glasses and we were where it all started
because you've lost a pair of glasses
and you realize it cost too much yeah it
was what was it six hundred dollars you
were told you lasted me $700 it's been
around for 800 years didn't make any
sense and so we realized that we could
cut out all the middlemen all the
unnecessary markups and so design the
product that we would love and want to
wear and sell them direct to consumers
for ninety five dollars back to Neal's
point I remember going to your office
and we were just sort of it was a
warehouse look you like my glasses
Parker's today I have a lot of your
stuff as you know but you go to the
office it wasn't all that attractive
fast forward to where we are to now it's
even affected how you design the stores
because you never expected to have
standing stores talk about the design
and the experience you want us to have
when we
absolutely so we launched exclusively
online now we have 47 stores 11:25 this
year and there are a lot of companies
that are closing stores and there's been
talk about the death of bricks and
mortar but for us we're seeing anytime
we open a store there's just an amazing
reception from our customers and we've
really designed them to be fun and make
it convenient for for customers we're
touch the glass is number one right
instead of being instead of having
frames behind lock and key we have all
the frames out in the open we've
designed our own technology so a point
of sale is on an iPad and we have just
great customer service and so we've
really tried to make it as convenient as
fun as possible and you have an
optometrist in the store which i think
is so great I mean when I joined CBS
this morning Gail and Charlie said well
you need new glasses you should go to
Warby Parker because it's it's an
expense I said no I've got a really bad
prescription it's always a
thousand-dollar suit no it'll be 150
bucks when you go to work and they were
right I mean you why are glasses so
expensive not at your store but what is
it and I learned it's a monopoly right
essentially I'm enough almost monopoly
yeah yeah there are two very large
companies that actually just announced
that they're gonna merge George yeah so
luxottica and SL are going to merge and
be a fifty five billion dollar company
so they own oakley ray-ban Oliver
Peoples / Solon Arnett laughter Foster
Grant sunglass hut that's all one
company haul one company but when you
started you all didn't even think it was
going to be a success you didn't even
tell your parents that's all have you
you have little faith you didn't you
didn't even think that this was going to
work and so we we launched out of our
apartments when we were students about
seven years ago and we thought I
wouldn't swear at werden yes and you
know we thought we had a good idea but
we also talked to a lot of entrepreneurs
that said you know just because you
think you have a great idea just because
you put up a website doesn't mean
anyone's gonna come to it and now fast
forward seven years where we just
crossed the a thousand employee mark and
something that we're really proud of is
through our buy a pair give a pair
program we've distributed millions of
pairs of glasses to people in need
throughout the world and you're going to
Philadelphia because you point out you
point out that there are 1 billion
people around the world who don't have
access to glasses
it's crazy and if you think about what
that means - somebody's earning
potential or ability to provide for
their family to learn to learn so it
immediately sets people back we're
finding that even in America we have
students getting misdiagnosed as special
needs when they just need a pair of
glasses so we now have a program here in
New York City and in Baltimore in which
we're going into city schools providing
eye exams and then providing glasses and
actually designing glasses to allow kids
to choose from a bunch of different
options because we know if the glasses
aren't cool they're not gonna wear them
yeah now you're here because you're
going to Philadelphia going back home
for the first time so that's great 70
years yeah we just opened our latest
storm allayed so that was a fun
homecoming being back on campus and
seeing all our old professors back and
congratulate continued exactly just
great Thank You Man so just add some
more greens to the on collar sizes for
young children but other than that it's
great did Gail and I tell you we have
opinions really continuing customer
service you're welcome